- Quel âge as-tu ?
- 15 ans.
On va te faire faire un test.
Quelle est la date d'aujourd'hui ?
20 septembre...
Je veux dire 24 décembre.
- Ah oui ? De quelle année ?
- 1986.
C'était un grand enfant.
Il aimait allait vite
Dès que j'ai été assez grande pour tenir dessus, j'étais toujours avec lui sur son tricycle, pour la virée de ma vie.
Ouais!
Il profitait de chaque minute.
Il a vécu cinq vies.
Un pacifiste armé : une somme d'opposés
Un amant et un battant
Il n'était clairement pas un marionnette.
Ce n'était pas le genre de gars à qui
tu dis quoi faire.
Le cinéma ne l'a pas montré et ne pouvait pas le montrer.
Paul a toujours été un acteur avec un pied dedans et un pied dehors.
- Il aurait voulu disparaître.
- Où est-ce que tu vas ?
Au revoir Paul.
Il disait toujours vouloir devenir garde forestier.
Gagner 28 000 à l'année et vivre dans la nature.
C'était quelque chose qu'il voulait vraiment faire.
Ma fille, le surf.
Ca c'est la vie.
Et c'est tout ce dont je me soucis.
Je peux dire qu'il a fait beaucoup de choses
qui ont eu un vraiment impact dans la vie de beaucoup de personnes.
Il avait le cœur sur la main.
Si vous l'avez aimé comme nous l'avons aimé ; vous vous diriez
Pourquoi lui et pas nous ?